تحدث
الان
الجميع
والاشخاص قلقون عندما يرى سيارته الاسعاف
كلها
تعرف باننا نتصرف بشكل طار وزياده الساعات
الاسره باضافه 7000 سرير اضافيه
العامه هي المجتمع والتفريق الاسره
والصحه تعملوا بالشكل على خطه مستقبليه
لسيارات الاسعاف وفيما يخص الاضرابات
هنالك الكثير من المعلومات المغلوطه لذلك
ومن الجميع ان يدرك به موقف الحكومه نحن
نقيم بشكل كبير ام القطاع عامه
يقومون بعمل هام جدا ولهذا السبب نحن نريد
حوارا عقول مع نقابات فيما هو مسؤول ومنصف
لبلادنا وفي الايام المقبله سوف نحدثكم في
ما يخص خطوات الحكومه القادمه اليوم
اودون ان اقدم التزاما بسيطا هذه الحكومه
دائما ستعكس اولويات
الشعبالا من السياسيين الذين يعدون بكل
شيء ويفشلون
الحكومه
واكثر على الاشياء التي تهمهم تكلفه
المعيشه مرتفعات جدا اوقات الانتظار في
دائره الصحه طويله جدا
همم الهجره غير الشرعيه كثيره وكبيره جدا
اعتقد بانهم يقبلونها ويدركون بان كثير
منها التحديات جزءا هيرتا من الكوب 19
واثار الحرب في اوكرانيا
ولكن هذا ليس بالعذر يجب ان نعالج هذه
المشاكل وليس فقط التحدث عنها ومنذ تولد
منصب رئيس الوزراء حققنا التقدم وهو حقنا
الاستقرار في الاقتصاد وفن المليارات من
الدعم التي تكلفه
الصحه العامه
حول العالم حول كل شيء من اوكرانيا الى
امن الاقتصادي المشترك واستمر بدعمنا
المستمر للقوات المسلحه والجهودها
المحافظه على امنيه
انعدام العداله للهجره غير القانونيه ولكن
بالتاكيد
يجب ان نفعل المزيد لذلك او ادو ان اقدمها
خمسه وعود لكم اليوم خمسه تعاهدات
لتحقيق راحه بالكم من خمسه اسس
نبني عليها مستقبل افضل لاطفالنا واحفادنا
اولا
سوف سوف
عبر البلاد ثالثا
سوف نضمن وان ديننا القومي ينخفض لكي
نؤمننا مستقبل الخدمات العامه رابعا
دائره الصحه واوقات الانتظار سوف تتقلص
وسيحصل جميع على رعايههم بحاجه عليه اليها
اسرع خامسا سوف نمر القوانين الجديده لوقف
القوارب الصغيره
سوف يبعد عنها اذا خمسه وعود وحاضشه
الدين ونخلص وقت الانتظار ونوقف القوارب
هذه هي اولويات الشعب وهي اولويات حكماتهم
واما ان نحققها او لا بدون حيل وبدون ايضا
اما ان نعمله من اجلكم او ان اعمل سوف
نعيد بناء السياسه عبر العمل او
بدنا نعمل شيئا لذلك اطلب منكم ان تحكموا
علينا حسب الجهود التي نذولاها والنتائج
التي نحققها
هذه الوعود على الخمسه هي اولويات الشعبان
لذلك هي اولوياتي الفوريه ايضا ولكنها الا
ليست حدود طموحات لبلادنا بل هي الاساس
هدفي هواء بناء مستقبل افضل لاطفالنا
واحفادنا المستقبل
يتحدثون كثيرا على التغيير ولكن الحقيقه
هي ان لا حكومه ولا رئيس وزراء بامكاني
تغيير
الاراده او فقط بالكلام التغيير الحقيقي
لا يوفر لا يمنح بل يطالب به ولا يمنح بل
يبتكر
الخيارات الى بتاخدها كافراد كعمال واصحاب
شركه واعمال كلها
تصل الى مرحله عمقه بكثير وان كنا صادقين
فالتغيير ايضا يتطلب التضحيه
والعمل الجاد
خطر كبير
ولكن المخاطر عاليه جدا
والمكافاه عاليه وكبيره ولذلك معكم
فالتغيير صعب ويستغرق الوقت
ولكنه ممكن ونحن نعرف ذلك لاننا سبق وان
حققنا ذلك خلال كوبا قمنا بحمايته من اين
الوظائف والاعمال وهذا الشيء انا افخر به
وانا اعرف ان ذلك ممكن ترون تغييره
وتشعرورون
الى المدارس
التي تنتج افضل النتائج هؤلاء المعلمون
والطلبه يعملون بايجاد ويقدمون التضحيات
لانهم يعرفون بان ما يقومون به اكبر من
مجرد انفسهم هم
صبايا يطالبون ويلهمون ويقدمون التميز
وهذا الا التميز يمكن ان يصبح هو الروحيه
روحيه امتي
المستلمين بهم معا نستطيع ان نغير شخصيه
بلادنا وان نعكس درجات القبول لخطابل
للحجار
على طموحاتنا ومن اجل فعل ذلك
فيجب ان يكون لدينا الخيال والثقه لتفعل
الاشياء بشكل مختلف وافضل ان رؤيه
ليه المطلوب اليوم اللي ما هو مطلوب في
المستقبل بكلمات اخرى يجب ان يغير اسلوب
عمل بلادنا وهذا يتطلب تغيير في العقليات
ما معنى ذلك على ارض الواقع هو يعني
اقتصاد ابتكاريا اكبر ومجتماعات اقوى
وشوارعها
وتعليم بمستوى عالي ودار الصحه مبنيه على
المرضى ومجتمع
يقيموا بحق قيام العائله وفي كل هذه
المجالات وغيرها يجب ان يتحلى بالشجاعه
للتغيير
ولا نستسلم عندما تصعب الامور واذا ما
تمكننا من فعل ذلك
فبمكائنا بحق بناء مستقبل افضل في الاشهر
القادمه سيحدث خططنا في كل هذه المجالات
ولكن اسمحوا لي نوضح المسار اليوم
مستقبل افضل هو اقتصادنا فيه ينمو بشكل
اسرع لكي يتمكن الجميع في كافه انحاء
بلادنا يحصل على فرص جديده من اجل مرتبات
ووظائف افضل والتغيير
الابتكارات واشياء جميله عليها
الماضي ولكن هذا هذه هي العقليه بالذات
التي يجب ان نغيرها اسمحوا اللي انا اقول
لكم لماذا الابتكار مهم للغايه عبر 50
عاما الماضيه كانت مسؤوله عن حوالي
زياده انتاجيه بريطانيا
ازدادت على الطريقه
المنت ولا خدمات خفضت بالاتيكار والتحديات
الكبرى مثل امن الطاقه والصافيه